me han pedido que hagan más ejercicios
sobre la derivación implícita así que
intentaré hacer un par de ejercicios más
yo sé que al principio esta derivación
es un poco más difícil y tal vez los
confunda sin embargo después le van a
agarrar y van a ver que no es tan
difícil
la persona que me envió este problema es
pero espero que realmente haya sido este
problema que me haya enviado decía algo
así era un problema que decía x cuadrada
ya esto había que restarle 24 veces xy y
ya todo esto hay que agregarle 16 veces
y encuadrada y después hay que restarle
400 veces equis y ya por último restarle
300 veces y esto es igual a cero y bueno
nosotros ya sabemos que si queremos la
derivación implícita podemos tomar las
derivadas de ambos lados con respecto a
equis y como ya hemos hecho esto varias
veces me voy a ahorrar el paso de poner
la derivada con respecto x de un lado y
de otro y mejoría vamos a derivar que no
es la derivada de x cuadrada pues es 2x
esto es muy sencillo y después la
derivada de 24
xy pues primero voy a actualizar el -24
lo voy a poner aquí menos 24 y ahora voy
a derivar la multiplicación de funciones
que tengo aquí es una multiplicación de
funciones y dice derivar primero la
primera función que es x y x la segunda
derivada de x es 1 ya estoy que
multiplicarlo por la segunda función la
segunda función es y entonces le voy a
poner tal cual ya esto sumarle la
segunda función tal cual sin derivar o
sea x ya estoy multiplicado por la
derivada de la segunda función es decir
la derivada de ella con respecto a x
pero es una función de x por lo tanto al
derivar la me va a quedar la derivada de
10 con respecto a equis o ye prima
entonces voy a poner a x que multiplica
a prima y bueno aquí acabo la derivada
de menos 24 x ya esto es por la
derivación implícita ya esto hay que
agregarle la derivada de 16 de cuadrada
entonces primero voy a derivar 16 de
cuadrada que sus derivadas 32
entonces voy a poner aquí 32 james ya
esto hay que multiplicarlo por la
derivada de que con respecto a x es como
si tuviéramos una regla de la cadena ya
tengo la derivada de la de afuera y hay
que multiplicarlo por la derivada de lo
de adentro que es la derivada de ella o
sea que prima esto por ello prima y
después la derivada de menos 400 x es
muy fácil menos 400 menos 400 ya esto
hay que restarle la derivada de menos
300 tiempo que es la derivada de menos
310-300 y como ya es una función de x
hay que multiplicarlo por la derivada de
ye con respecto a x es muy fácil cada
vez que ustedes vean allí o deriven algo
que tengan que ver con yes siempre hay
que poner allí prima por lo tanto aquí
estamos derivando a algo que tiene que
ver con jeff y entonces hay que
agregarle prima o la derivada de ye gon
respecto a x como ustedes gusten por lo
tanto menos 300 y al derivadas no me
queda menos 300 que es la derivada
normal y después hay que multiplicarlo
por la derivada de ella con respecto a x
osea y prima y esto es igual a la
derivada de 0 con respecto a x qué será
y ahora si lo que hay que hacer es
despejar allí por lo tanto solamente es
cuestión de álgebra me voy a quedar 2x y
esto lo voy a multiplicar menos 24 por
james y después menos 24 por x de prima
y a esto hay que sumarle pues 32 veces a
mi prima y a esto hay que restarle menos
400 y después menos 310 prima lo único
que voy a hacer es despejar allí prima y
por lo tanto si quiere despejar en prima
pues lo que se me ocurre es pasar todo
lo que no tiene que ver con mi prima del
otro lado de la ecuación pero antes que
eso primero vamos a factorizar allí
prima entonces este término tiene de
prima este de aquí también tiene área
prima y este último también entonces voy
a factorizar allí prima todos éstos
tienen bien prima por lo tanto vamos a
sacar factor común es por acosar álgebra
factor común y en prima que multiplica
quien primero voy a poner el término
positivo que es 32 bien y después los
negativos es lo mismo tener los
positivos y los negativos primero pero
bueno esto le va a dar más orden 32
menos 24 x menos 300 todo esto están x
que prima porque está que factor común y
ahora sí voy a poner lo que me sobra lo
que me sobra es 1
x 1 - 24 james y 1 menos 400 y todo esto
es igual a 0 y ahora si lo que se me
ocurre es pasar todo lo que no tenga que
ver con mi prima es decir todo lo que no
está factor izado del otro lado de la
ecuación para que los para ellos poder
despejar próximamente allí prima pasando
esto de aquí dividiendo entonces vamos a
hacerlo a me queda prima que nunca se
les olvide que prima es lo mismo que la
derivada de con respecto a x de hecho yo
lo pongo con ye prima para ahorrar
tiempo para no poner en cada renglón la
derivada de y con respecto a x pero
bueno ahora sí voy a despejar allí en
prima y en prima estaba multiplicando a
todo esto de aquí es decir a 32 menos 24
x menos 300 y esto es igual a los otros
términos pero ahora le voy a cambiar el
signo entonces me va a quedar a 24 oye
- 2 x + 400 y ahora si es muy sencillo
porque yo lo único que necesitas pasar
todo esto dividiendo por lo tanto lo voy
a hacer una vez y en prima ahora sí ya
estoy despejando a ye prima o la
derivada de con respecto a x es igual a
primero pues lo que está arriba que es
24 bien menos 2 x más 400 y lo demás lo
voy a pasar dividiendo porque ésta va
multiplicando pasa del otro lado
dividiendo 32 menos 24 x menos 300 y
bueno ya casi acabamos de hecho es lo
que me doy cuenta aquí es que todo se
puede dividir entre dos y operamos
acabado pero todavía se puede dividir y
reducir un poco entonces vamos a hacerlo
a 24 la mitad es 12 la mitad de 2 es uno
y la mitad de 400 es 200 y todo esto
entre por las mitades 16 james menos 12
x
2 150 y ahora sí ya acabamos este
problema ya tengo yo la derivada de ye
con respecto a x despejada y ya tengo
estudiante cuenta una cosa yo aquí tenía
un monstruo de función tiene una función
bien difícil y ahora sí ya puedo saber
la pendiente de mi recta tangente en
cualquier punto de esta función entonces
vamos hacer otro ejercicio el siguiente
ejercicio es a creo que es un poco más
sencillo me queda x menos todo esto
elevado al cuadrado y esto va a ser
igual a 8 veces ya y entre paréntesis
menos 6 y bueno ahora lo que voy a hacer
aquí es otra vez usar la derivación
implícita y vamos a derivar primero la
parte izquierda de esta igualdad pero si
se dan cuenta la parte izquierda esta
igualdad es una regla de la cadena
tenemos una función elevado a un
exponente entonces bueno yo lo podría
ser elevando de todo esto al cuadrado su
nombre cuadrado perfecto pero esta vez
lo voy a hacer con la regla de la cadena
para que se ponga más interesante
entonces qué dice la regla de la cadena
el 2 ponemos la función de al cual le
bajamos 1 al exponente 2 - 1 es uno
entonces solamente se queda así por la
derivada de lo que está acá adentro
entonces hay que multiplicar esto por la
derivada de lo de adentro la derivada lo
de adentro pues es la derivada de x con
respecto a x que es muy sencillo es uno
menos la derivada de ya con respecto a x
la derivada de y es uno pero hay que
multiplicarlo por que prima la derivada
de jake con respecto a x y ahora sí ya
tenemos completa toda esta derivada la
derivada de x menos
1 - la derivada de ella con respecto a x
y utilizamos la regla de la cadena y
ahora me falta derivar la parte derecha
de esta igualdad entonces vamos a
hacerlo tengo 8 que multiplica al menos
6 entonces primero voy a hacer esta esta
multiplicación para que sea mucho más
sencillo a 8 porque pues es 8 y james y
8 x menos 6 es menos 48 entonces me
queda 8 y menos 48 horas y derivar esto
es
a una posible y sencilla la derivada de
48 se va y la derivada de 8 pues es 8
que multiplica a la derivada de ye gon
respecto a x entonces me quedan 8 que
multiplica a la derivada de ya con
respecto a x ahi prima o la derivada de
con respecto a x lo voy a poner como la
derivada de ella con respecto a x para
seguir este formato y bueno la derivada
de 48 se faltó solamente me queda esto y
ahora tengo que despejar a la derivada
de ella con respecto a x entonces se me
ocurre que primero voy a multiplicar el
2 por todo lo que está acá adentro me
queda 2x minutos james que multiplica a
uno menos la derivada de jake con
respecto a x y esto es igual a 8 veces
la derivada del iac con respecto a x
bueno ahora lo que voy a hacer es
multiplicar estos dos binomios entonces
2x por 1 pues me queda 2x
2x por la derivada de ya con respecto a
x es 2x la derivada de ye con respecto a
x y ahora vamos con el menos 2 - 2 x 1
me va a quedar pues menos 2 james y
menos 2 x menos la derivada de llegó al
respecto x me queda más 2 y la derivada
de con respecto a x y ahora este 8
derivada de nye con respecto x lo voy a
pasar del otro lado para factorizar lo
que tenga que ver con esta derivada
entonces me va a quedar menos 8 veces la
derivada de jake con respecto a x y esto
va a ser igual a 0 pase el 8 veces la
derivada de llegó al respecto x del otro
lado con signo contrario y ahora sí voy
a factorizar lo que tenga que ver con la
derivada de y con respecto a x que son
esos tres términos entonces me queda a
aquí lo voy a escribir me va a quedar la
derivada de que con respecto a x
que va a multiplicar su vez primero voy
a poner los términos positivos que estoy
en dos y menos 2 x menos
8 muy fuerte el de aquí 2 2x menos 8
todo esto este x tigre sobre de x ya
esto hay que sumarle 2 veces x menos 2
veces y esto es igual a 0 y bueno ahora
voy a pasar todo lo que no está
multiplicando a la derivada de ya con
respecto a x del otro lado
entonces me quedan la derivada y con
respecto a x que multiplica a 2 - 2 x
menos 8 es igual y bueno primero voy a
poner el positivo que estos james y
después del negativo que es 2 x le
cambian los signos a los dos términos
que me quedaban sin multiplicará de
allende x y ahora sí para acabar lo
único que me resta es pasar todo lo que
está multiplicando a la derivada de ella
con respecto a x del otro lado
dividiendo entonces me quedan dos menos
dos equis entre y pues me queda dos
menos dos x menos ocho que estaban
multiplicando a la derivada de con
respecto a x y como todo tiene mitad
vamos a sacárselo me queda menos x entre
tiene menos x menos 4 y eso es todo
espero que te haya servido mucho este
vídeo y nos vemos en el siguiente